for years now so our cameras have been
following Dr Paul you've seen him take
care of animals large and small angry
and adorable little ferocious thing
time we have a different story to tell
a Dutch farm boy grew up to be all
Incredible Dr Paul Auntie Fee I look
like a crazy large animal veterinarian
with an accent first time I'd ordered a
bowl
special good I hope that we can share a
little bit different Side of Me That You
Don't See all the time
you can call me anytime for this
a boy who grew up in the Netherlands and
dreamed of America
a man with a love story like you see in
the movies a Country Vet who became
famous around the world
this is the story of his incredible life
okay let's get busy
whole
as the veterinarian you have to save the
lives of animals I got this one yeah and
when you're in time and you can pull a
life calf it's the most rewarding part
of the business
look at that see okay
Dr Pol has been braving the nasty
Michigan weather for decades answering
emergency calls from Farmers like Butch
black
I have a cow on here one to calf my
husband believes that it's dead
she's the first time ever yep I can tell
Charles chains yeah coming I think the
most memorable film case was the calving
that we did in the rain it was just an
experience that I'll remember for my
entire life
I've had very many difficult booths
it always has been my motto that do the
best you can never give up
and tell it like it is oh pull over
I know I'm gonna lose the calf probably
well we're gonna see
working in frigid rain Dr Pol doesn't
know if the calf is even alive thank you
I don't know they definitely felt the
rain and I definitely heard the Thunder
but it made no difference you know I was
there to pull a calf I got it
underneath
the calf isn't breathing
I got it yep
get it out of there doc knows the next
few minutes are critical and he's not
giving up he's alive
water
okay
and even as dramatic as it was on
television it was even more dramatic in
person
and down
and the calf started breathing yeah
there he goes maybe a little bit don't
give up your sucker yeah
[Music]
ah Charles yeah
seen that calf come out alive and my dad
basically bring it to life it it was
something one lucky sucker there ain't I
good job I felt a palpable energy and I
think the entire crew kind of shared
that
yeah if you're a part of it
s energy bleeds over because he's
psyched and you feel it you're there
breathe
and we got alive
and we were talking about it for weeks
after because it was a great great
moment
oh that brought tears to my eyes
and when that came out alive actually
that was you know the cream in the
coffee
it's just another day in the life of a
man who never set out to be incredible
[Music]
His Story begins over 70 years ago blown
away from his home in central Michigan
come on daughter
I was born and raised in the Netherlands
in a very small rural area
where my deadheaded daddy Farm
growing up we had the cows we had the
horses we had chickens we had pigs oh
it's gonna be super pretty quick
what did we have I always like the
animals you know I had never any problem
getting up in the morning and helping my
dad worked with the couch when all the
other kids were gone
my sister was telling that I was taking
care of a chicken when I was like one
and a half two years old my father would
do away with it because she wasn't
laying eggs but of course I was trying
to take care of him catch
my mother was always trying to save
animals too and maybe that's what I got
from her
there were six of us I was before the
youngest in the local Dutch tradition
the Pole family house was connected to
the barn
hour hours at that time had no running
water we had no electricity we had a
cold stove in the house for heat
on the farm we always had food
yanpole was born in 1942 two and a half
years after Germany invaded the
Netherlands
I was raised in the Second World War I
don't remember much but I've heard the
stories
and tore apart Europe the polls adapted
to life in a country occupied by the
Nazis
his brothers were too young to serve his
father too old
the family stayed together tending to
their Farm
we were very lucky in the world
so when the Germans started deporting
all the Jews
the Dutch people just started Sheltering
him
despite the risk the polls took a
starving Jewish boy into their home
for me it was just you know a little
older brother and that's how he was
treated
the risk in their lives for a boy
[Music]
that was just regular Dutch people
thank you
[Music]
at the age of 12
something happened that changed the
course of Dr Paul's life
my brother young bought some pigs and
then they turned out to be pregnant and
he made me reach all the way up to my
armpit in order to get the piglets out
the ones that I cut out and started
squealing and looking so nice pink and
Rosy that was such a satisfying feeling
to save those little boogers
that's when I said okay I'll become a
veterinarian
[Music]
six decades later Doc's still right at
home on the farm
we're done a Daryl sofa on the van
I really like the area I like the people
that are here I thank you you're welcome
hello I came from a rural area in the
Netherlands so to be honest with it felt
like home right away
Jan was only 18 when he made his first
trip to the states
my sister moved to Canada in 1955 so we
really did not expect to see her many
times
he wanted to come this way because we
had been here for a number of years and
apparently my mom and dad were talking
about visiting and he wanted to go as an
exchange student then
he yearned to follow his sister across
the Atlantic
so he found an exchange program in
Michigan and applied
when you see North America on Page in
the atlas Ontario and Michigan is very
close together
so I ended up in Mayville
Mayville was a long way from the
Netherlands but somehow he would find
himself getting closer to home
[Music]
I first met Yan when he was an exchange
student to my high school he ended up
staying at my parents home when he first
showed up everybody else seemed to think
he was really good looking all the other
girls were really swooning over him but
yeah he was okay
Diane came out of the crowd first thing
I said mine she's tall
it was definitely not love at first
sight
if he got along fine it seemed like
Diane and I had the same interest and
awful lot we loved the beach we love to
go swimming so we had a lot of hobbies
that were together
I think my dad had always wanted to have
a son well he
on left we were really good friends
there was a little spark but he was
going back to the Netherlands and I was
starting my college Diane left home to
become a teacher Yan went back home to
become a doctor
veterinary school was in Utrecht the
Netherlands you didn't have to be
accepted you just went there
there were like 300 students that wanted
to become veterinarians they only had
room for a hundred
so the first couple exams they weeded
half of them out
of the 300 that started only 96 became
veterinarians
and I'm one of them
[Music]
you have to let the animal tell you what
is going on with it
back when I was in school they told us
you examine an animal that means you
look at it you feel it you listen and if
necessary smell it
I'm a Hands-On guy in the final year of
vet school
we didn't have to study out of books
anymore everything was Hands-On I flew
through it
in 1970 Mr yonpol became Dr yonpol
and he's basically been on call ever
since
in college he told us hey get your shirt
off get in there
because it didn't Supply aprons for us
now it's the same thing my skin washes a
lot easier than my clothes because if
you get all that Blood Sweat and Tears
and anything else in your clothes the
spots don't come out my skin cleans as
easy as anything else and it doesn't
bother me one bit
[Laughter]
[Music]
pole veterinary services this is Diane
Jan and Diane have been married for
nearly 50 years we've got quite a few
calls on the list you know there's a
saying behind any successful man
there is a strong woman
Diane is the boss what do you think yeah
she tells us where to go all right I'll
let him know all right thank you I think
when we first met we had no idea that
anything would ever develop between the
two of us
[Music]
with an ocean separating the two their
relationship matured through letters
[Music]
now without the leather in the mail on
Sunday night and she would have it
Wednesday through the years we began to
realize that we had a romance budding I
think the summer that I spent over in
Europe was the summer that we actually
fell in love with each other that was
that was the time when you know my
father was dying
and she just kept things going while we
were taking care of my dad and she was
there
about two years later he came back over
to the United States he proposed to me I
made him through the whole official
thing and
[Music]
they were married in the summer of 1967.
browser
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay what were we saying
I lost my train of thought
[Music]
doc never had any interest in starting a
practice in the Netherlands
when I was in college I bought all
English books yes I was ready to go
farther away than anybody else
they opted to go somewhere familiar
Diane's hometown of Mayville Michigan
we ended up staying with my family while
he went around with some of the local
veterinarians so that he could get used
to the way things were done here
after a decade of working for others he
was ready it was time for him to be his
own boss
basically is I don't take orders
I'm a stubborn induction and I wanted to
do it my way and the only way you can do
that is to open up your own practice and
have nobody tell you how that it has to
be done
Dr Paul and Diane searched for just the
right place to put down roots
we did some research and we found out
that there were not many large animal
veterinaries practicing in this area
while Isabella was one of the highest
counties for cows pigs and other animals
Weidman Michigan is where they settled
before he had a chance to hang out his
shingle there was a call for help
my first case in Weightman was pulling a
live calf I wasn't even ready I didn't
have all my instruments didn't have all
the medicine didn't have all the
equipment
Ready or Not the farmer needed him
I I can't do anything I didn't even ever
care for it yet he said okay we'll get
one for you
so I went out use the other guy's calf
pulling and pulled a live cat and he
said how much he says I'm sorry but I
cannot charge you for this
here I'm doing your service and you're
fine thank you very much glad you called
word quickly spread there's a new vet in
the area he has a funny accent but he's
a straight shooter I was running my full
head off pretty quick it was just work
we got a practice started and it took
off like wildfire
first we saw the the large animal you
know mainly cows horses pigs
as the years passed Dr Paul built a
loyal client base
[Music]
Dr Paul is my veterinarian and I
consider a good friend Bill Stowe has
trusted Dr Pohl with the care of his
cows for 15 years
these guys are going too fast for me
for the styles to stay in business
Bill's cows need to make milk cows have
to get pregnant otherwise they can't
give milk no pregnant cows means no
payday
so one of Doc's main jobs pregnancy
checks
now always have the bottom line in my
mind
on a recent visit doc done his glove and
found out many of Bill's cows weren't
carrying calves
why isn't this one pregnant
you're the doctor you're supposed to
tell us I told them that they are
feeding way too much calcium and not
enough phosphorus
we changed the diet so it seems to make
the difference for
not a pregnancy check cows and the first
three pregnant pregnant
let's keep going
pregnant
that's a plus yes we're doing good
his his goal is our goal 16 positives
that's what I thought better than that
yes I know
man alive
clay knob Dairy is run by the Leonard
Brothers Phil and Dale they're also
longtime clients of Dr Pol
let's keep going keep pulling keep
pulling punch it wants it
over the years Dr polis proved his worth
and in the process save them a lot of
money
[Music]
first time I remember he came out
had a couple of sore foot and usually in
that situation like that the guy we
ended up getting rid of it because we
couldn't fix it right the next thing you
know he's hooked into the top of the
barn there and the trusses his foot was
up he's in there working covering on it
and I just like
really
though when they find out that you know
what you're doing
and you treat him honestly well I tell
guys then they get used to you very fast
and call you oh what a smell
hahaha
before long the hard-working Dutchman
had a thriving large animal vet practice
turns out it was only the beginning next
thing we knew people were knocking down
the door and saying my dog just got hit
by a car can you take care of it
by 1981 the words out in central
Michigan there's a new vet in town and
he's good I've never taken out an ad
saying I'm Buffet tonight and come and
call me
we first started we figured that we
would be doing probably completely large
animal
pretty soon we had so many people coming
they were lining up outside our door so
we set up a little corner of our garage
business quickly outgrew their garage
in 1986 the polls broke ground on their
Clinic
the base started at a gallop
it hasn't slowed down since
thank you
pull Veterinary Services is open for
business six days a week and there's
always a vet on call
[Music]
ing back
each week hundreds of people flock to
the clinic to put their trust in Dr
Paul's talented staff
VC appointments every 15 minutes oh
right in my face it is just crazy white
blood cells are high see that yeah you
don't worry about the next one that's
coming
how are you or the one that's behind
okay and if you pee on me I'll spit on
you and you work through it hey
quiet
Through The Years people have realized
that I'm willing to take on any animal
[Music]
whatever they bring through the doors
we will help them
what is the problem I believe he has
parasites
and porcupine quills yikes
hey you're the cute guy it's a girl girl
a business like this you kind of do by
yourself Diane did the books I did the
work and together we built this practice
yes and together they built a family
Dr Paul and I wanted a life with
children and we could not have children
of our own so we decided that we were
going to adopt
I cannot imagine life without children
Kathy came first then Charles
and then Diane Jr came last
the 80s was a good decade for us the
kids were home I love having kids around
and we were starting a business and the
business was growing and doing well and
it was just a happy time
when I was a little boy my dad was like
a superhero to me he was
huge and strong and
you know threw around bowls
you know just seems to be the toughest
roughest strongest fastest guy you've
ever seen
they've given us a lot of grief but a
lot more joy and
still everybody's very close
it was difficult
veterinarian and trying to raise kids at
the same time
[Laughter]
but we always ate our dinner together
sometimes it was 9 or 9 30 at night
before he got home from Farm calls and
we could sit down and have dinner
together if we wanted to hang out with
Dad we would go out and the room in our
garage and and hang out with him while
he was doing his space and castrations
at nine o'clock at night
and as if On Cue an emergency call yet
another family dinner interrupted by
work how bad is it first he tries to
triage the case over the phone okay a
couple Band-Aids over the top of it to
make it tight
an emergency after close while we're
eating
you cannot separate business and home
life
a lot of times he would get up at two in
the morning
and go out on an emergency and you guys
stay this one's severe in need of
treatment see you later
in a business like this you are on call
24 7.
I don't mind
they know it they're used to it they
know it's part of the the business that
we have there's nothing we can do about
it
the client is desperate
Amanda McCauley's pet has been attacked
by a rat Dr Pol is the only vet who will
see her the rats started biting him
making a full course meal of him he has
big wounds on on Oliver's Body and his
face is all bitten up
come on sweetie
[Music]
this is not good
yep the life of a Country Vet is a life
on call
you guys stay
today is no different
Amanda's pet snake was attacked
we put a rat in for him to eat and he
didn't eat it
so what the the red started biting him
um making a full course meal of him come
on sweetie
along the back that rat just had a good
meal of some tender snake meat
but this is not good
to deal with the snake
so I called Dr Pol and I'm like I I have
no one no one wants to even touch him we
had healed that up oh good we are not
going to give it up that easy hi sweetie
good the wounds were so bad I thought
the worst I thought he was gonna die
I've seen it worse
I'm hoping Dr Paul can
work some magic and and get him healed
I can pull the skin together over the
top so I don't give up easy
thank you hey thank you
Dr Poland is just awesome I am just
overwhelmed I mean he handled everything
just beautifully well it's better than
you expected yes
Dr Paul was the vet on call today
but most days he's not the only one on
the other end of the phone
now he has more than a dozen people
working for him
[Music]
as we started expanding the people that
we hired we took in as part of our
family
Dr Brenda is the senior vet at the
clinic she was hired right after she
graduated vet school I knew right away
that I wanted to be part of the practice
here it's like a big family the way the
clinic is run and I really feel quite at
home here
but the process from scratch
good days and bad days the good days far
away the bad days otherwise I wouldn't
have stayed so long very good because
I'm glad you like it it's pretty good
I remember as a kid like being over
there and and feeling like that was part
of my extended family
many people in the clinic have worked
for us many many years today finding
vets interested in treating large
animals is challenging when doc put out
word he needed to hire a new vet Emily
Thomas answered the call
I'm the new vet at pole Veterinary I'm
excited to be here
I try to show new veterinarians how I do
things
I like getting out on the farms you get
to play with cows
ah but the uh the Newbie Dr Emily hello
this is Dale this is Phil Dale and Phil
stomach is working good good but step
aside when the tail goes up
that's her manure though yep manure
doesn't bother me one bit I could eat a
hamburger while palpate and cows oh yeah
this is kind of wrong
[Music]
I smell ketosis I've never been able to
smell that ketosis the cow's blood sugar
level is dangerously low
it's a dirty sweet smell not fairly
agreeable even Dr Pol had to learn the
distinctive odor you have to teach your
nose how to smell it basically because
for years I couldn't smell it until I
had a cow that was so bad ketosis that
you know you walked in the barn and wait
a minute is that ketosis and from there
on now I know what it smells like
a little dextrose is the cure
but another one of Dale's cows has a
displaced Eva Mason one of her stomach
Chambers is out of place a potentially
fatal condition many petenans will do
surgery but the farmers here prefer us
doing the rolling Stitch which is
something that she's never done
Dr Pohl learned this technique during
vet school in the Netherlands
it's pretty exciting because it was the
first time she did a rolling Stitch
because the stomach is full of gas the
gas pulls the stomach right in this
place where it's supposed to be hear
that yeah
yeah and with our big needles we
anchored the stomach right to the belly
hole watch this ready
I put the first stitch in with the tip
of the needle you can feel whether
you're in the upper Mason because the
affirmation is smooth let her feel a
little bit how it goes feel this see
then she can do the second Stitch so she
knows how it feels like okay so straight
in yep straight in deeper
deeper oh yeah she did fine it was a new
procedure for her but that was all roll
it through roll it through
good I think I might need to see one
more rolling Stitch before I am ready
for myself but I can do it okay let's go
when dark's not teaching classic vet
procedures
he's busy inventing his own
the vehicle prolapse rings for pigs if
you buy them they're expensive so I
figured hey you know I can make it
myself I'm gonna use this prolapse tube
we're going to slide that in the inside
of the rectum
okay let it go
[Music]
when you have a broken leg on a calf you
just use a bunch of cotton a bushel
basket
and that is enough stabilization for a
leg to heal
and I think that's enough yep that'll do
docs Ingenuity helps the bottom line
but his compassion keeps clients coming
back generation after generation
I'm looking for the best interest of the
animal
today a horse is stricken with a bad
case of founder which is a crippling and
often fatal disease
foundered terribly yeah I see that
the hoofs are just completely malformed
so it's very painful for the horse to
walk come on sweet
I knew it was time it was past time and
he could tell as soon as he saw her
when an animal becomes so sick
that the quality of life is completely
gone for it
then let it go
well
euthanasius is part of the job but it's
not the nice part we went to school to
help animals not to kill them
here so be the first time I've been
without any
I think my dad is excellent with helping
people cope with the pain that they feel
when they lose an animal
[Music]
euthanasias are probably the hardest
part of Jan's job even though he knows
that it's best for the animal it's never
easy
to eliminate suffering he adopted a
two-step approach
what I do with any animal they get
tranquilizers by that time they are out
far enough that they don't know what's
going on and that's when I go with the
big needle and go right directly into
the heart and stop the heart
I'm not going away until I know for sure
no more horses huh nope
many times I cry with him they get joked
because you know we've had so many pets
and our pets have to die
[Music]
when you see a horse euthanasia it's
never easy
but then you go on the next Farm call
and some days he pulls a live calf so
it's a roller coaster and every day is
different
and every day there's risk
many farmers have been killed by Bulls
Roger don't turn your back on an Angus
Bowl
look at the cows and they'll tell you
whether they're going to run over you
kick you or you know trample you to
death
come on there's no question this is a
dangerous job
it's just like being a matador correct
watch out
[Music]
man I'll lie Dave
we work in situations that are dangerous
Charles she's pushing this board that's
okay
these animals they're strong and they
can hurt you in a blink of an eye
yeah
the minute you turn your back you're
done for
Hey Jake
thank you
son of it I turned my head for a moment
and she nailed me
cow was able to get under the pipe
and kick him in the leg oh it hurts man
Allah how did she cut underneath that
pipe
after 30 years of this many people might
consider kicking back and retiring
not Dr Paul instead he chose to double
down and pick up a second job
watch it move
until a few years ago most of the world
had never heard of Dr John Pol
o
one man saw the potential and had an
idea I was working Los Angeles and I
said you know my dad would make a really
interesting reality show subject he's a
he's a character okay who's got the
hemorrhoids around here
so Charles came and says that we should
make a reality show about you and I
thought who the heck cares you know
nobody want to watch me
so he brought two friends and a filmer
and they were filming us for a week
first met him
at the Grand Rapids airport he was
Extremely Loud
he was driving like a maniac I just met
him and he already told me to shut up
twice
shut up that's it Ray but I knew like
this guy is the kind of guy that you can
base a television series off of he was
just humongous big 10 days go ahead pull
the stitches out and basically the rest
is history
[Music]
a star of a TV show
getting used
to see you in something besides yeah I
even took a shower
in the beginning it was a little weird
that the people were following me all
over the place but we have developed a
very good system
thanks guys
get away it's me watch it move
following Dr Pol is like uh it's like
the running of the bulls
oh they're crazy a lot of times
literally
shut up
you know when we go on Farm calls
there's a crew that goes ahead
my work on the farm is not compromised
by all this filament
Dr Pol appreciates the fact that we're
working around him and not asking him to
stop
the animal still comes first so when
they are in a way
I will tell him
move
come on Mama
[Music]
hang on the challenge of making the show
is that it's real
we don't do retakes
holy cow it's basically you know when I
tried to pull a calf the film crew has
to be there the very first time and get
it right because I'm not putting that
calf back in the car to pull a second
take
is she breathing it should be fine
we are still doing the best we can
helping animals
[Music]
this is why the show is so popular
can we take a picture with you come
behind us okay
[Music]
cool because he helps animals and
um
it's different Adventures
he has more than 19 000 patients and
he's here with us tonight ladies and
Gentlemen let's give a big down Diamond
welcome the incredible doctor
[Music]
thank you thank you
I'm Dr Paul
Dr Paul's success has given him a
platform to get his message out it's all
about animals
I think my dad feels that if he can
Inspire one kid to consider a career
with animals whether it's veterinary
medicine or being a farmer everything
that he has to do for this show is
worthwhile when kids grow up with
animals have to take care of animals
they make better adults later on again
thanks very much for inviting us over
for this beautiful event thank you
foreign
[Music]
for me I'm not incredible you know what
I do is very credible and believable
it is just that I do care and try to do
the best I can for the animal for the
owner and have been very successful
where you going
what
cute out of me
when he gets home from work and the
cameras aren't around I do not call him
the Incredible Dr Paul I say get to work
Dr Polson
in motion
even on his days off he doesn't sit
still
you know if you sit still
you start resting
I plan to stick around for a long time
yet so the motor move now the better it
will be
[Music]
lives up to his name the Incredible Dr
pole but he will never admit that so I
just want to thank you very much for
everything that you do for 4-H in
Isabella County thank you very much
okay
[Applause]
John does do a lot for the community
I beseech you there for Brethren by the
mercies of God
but having lived here all this time and
raising our family here and growing our
business here I feel like we've received
so much more more power to the class of
19 of that's the walk
more power to the class of 2013
[Applause]
as teenagers Dr Paul and Diane first met
in Mayville Michigan now it's time for
their triumphant return to the place
where it all began we have our grand
Marshals The Incredible Dr Paul and his
wife Diane originally from Mayville
[Music]
47 years everything got married here
it's unbelievable right over there is
where Dad gave me the first kiss on the
ice skating oh yeah
why not
[Laughter]
okay
thank you
the right place
[Music]
how many people can say that they can
work with their dad every day doing
something that they love to do
I wouldn't trade it for the world hi
I'm thankful for what happened to us and
how it all developed I I'm not proud I'm
happy
[Music]
crazy isn't it yeah sure
cheering on the sidelines
hello this is Dr Paul
[Music]
yes oh veterinary medicine doesn't get
old
helping animals never gets old
[Music]
bye see ya
retirement's a dirty word I don't think
Jan's ever going to retire
heck yes I will retire I just don't know
when
[Music]
as long as I can keep going
I love it let's get busy
if I die with my arm up a cow's butt
ready let go I know that I've had a good
life and I enjoyed what I was doing
oh
there you go already thank you you're
very welcome thanks guys to all the fans
in this show thank you for watching it's
amazing that this show became so popular
I never thought it would happen I think
all my fans for watching all the time
[Music]
thank you